Daniel Snyder the Washington owner has a
predicament it's unclear whether he's
acknowledged that to himself or anyone
else but the pressure is continuing to
mount on Snyder changed the name of his
team to developments from Wednesday
at 87 investment firms that represent
620 billion in assets putting pressure
on Nike Pepsi and FedEx to stop doing
business with the Washington franchise
until it changes its name now FedEx is
important here because FedEx Field is
the name of a place where the team plays
and also Fred Smith the CEO of FedEx is
one of the owners of the franchise if
you start putting pressure on Fred Smith
and maybe he puts pressure on daniel
snyder maybe right maybe so of those
three companies I think FedEx is the one
that people need to focus on if you want
to get the attention eventually of Dan
Schneider but this is the first time
this issues been hanging around for
seven years now
this is the first time there's been any
type of pressure placed upon the
sponsors of the franchise also and this
one has kind of been percolating out
there we've known it's going this way
but forget about having a new stadium on
the side of RFK Stadium unless and until
the name changed that's something that
Snyder would like to do and part of the
bargain is going to be give up the name
now look the cynical side of me has
believed it's Snyder is just holding
back changing the name so he can
leverage it for some tangible benefit
whether it's more money to build a
stadium whether it's a draft in DC
whether it's an open air cold weather
Super Bowl in DC whatever the case may
be I feel like he's been holding it back
for the right time to trade it for
something and by saying as he did
several years ago all caps never will he
change the name that just puffs up the
value of the thing that he eventually
would turn in for some consideration
coming back to him but in this moment it
is not like he's gonna get anything in
return for doing it
the question is will there be enough
pressure put on him that he has to do
something now to end this discussion I
still don't know whether or not the
discussion is even registered and it
astounds me that he doesn't see the
parallels between himself and George
Preston Marshall that 40 or 50 years
from now
Snyder will be getting the same kind of
treatment that Marshall is getting now
of course Snyder hasn't done anything to
merit a monument or placement in the
ring of on or anything like that so it's
not like the
is anything that would be tangible that
could be taken away years from now but
you don't wanna be remember that way so
I just don't know what the endgame here
is for the team other than I believe to
run out the clock and hope that
eventually we'll all move on to
something else
and the franchise will be allowed to
continue with a name that is a
dictionary to find racial slur but that
no one is applying the kind of pressure
on Schneider to get him to change period
including the lead I don't know what's
going on behind the scenes but I haven't
heard anything if the NFL was intent on
getting him to change the name and if
the NFL was talking to him behind the
scenes somebody from the league office
would leak that to reporters because
that allows the NFL to look good they
they don't look like they're being
disrespectful they're not going public
but sources with knowledge of the
situation have confirmed that yada yada
yada that's a way to get it out there
the league is doing something right now
the league is doing nothing and I think
the league is complicit and people have
said to me well why are you giving Ron
Rivera hard time about this whoa he's
the only guy who's out there talk
Schneider is nowhere to be seen
Rivera was on radio in Chicago three
days ago and he said that the issue of
the name changes a discussion for
another time
we criticized him for that because if
now is at the time when is well why are
you giving Ron Rivera our time he's just
an employee well he has said he's the
leader of the franchise and he's
empowered to run the organization and he
believes actions speak louder than words
so I think he is somebody who could be
singled out but secondly Snyder's not
doing these interviews Snyder's not
making himself available
Snyder's not answering any of these
questions think about what he said back
in 2013 when he said put it down in all
caps I'll never change the name think of
how that would go over if he would do it
now that's why he's not saying anything
and I continue to hold out hope that
players will eventually say something
that's the next frontier in all of this
you start having people who are employed
by the organization and who will stand
up and talk now look I'm gonna get the
same reaction why are you putting
pressure on these guys they're just
trying to get a paycheck they're just
trying to play football why do you want
them to say something well what was
gonna get cut
if Dwayne Haskins says something's gonna
get benched if Adrian Peterson says
something is he gonna get
cut Terry Maclaurin chase young you
think chase young is gonna suffer any
consequence whatsoever if he says you
know I've been thinking about this and
chase young is a very conscientious
young man
chase young decided that he wasn't gonna
work out at the compound he wasn't gonna
give in to the pressure that gets put on
these players to entertain the rest of
us in late february when there's no
football going on he understands the
business if he has a moment of
conscience why couldn't he say yeah I
don't think that's a good name I think
they need to change it I think that's
the next frontier the question is will
the name change now will it change later
and what will be the legacy of the
people who participated and enabled the
ongoing existence of this name beyond
this moment forget about the last seven
years this is the moment where the
change needs to happen this does the
reckoning and awakening on all matters
of race this is the time for it to
happen and the clock is ticking loud
like and legacies are on the line and
we'll see if anybody steps up and does
the right thing
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports